this situation should be dissolved
somehow
well we're hoping for for something to
come out of it but for right now it's
all about the chest that's being
produced on the board and Knight H5 you
mentioned this move and immediately it's
almost like Prague was ready for it he
immediately blitzes out Knight C3 so
fighting against that idea of trades on
E2 and the F4 Pawn uh is lost but Peter
did Hans missed Knight C3 because now if
you go Queen D6 putting pressure on F4
that allows Knight E4 yeah absolutely I
mean okay I was expecting to move Queen
F5 to win this but Knight E4 will be
played and then also some Fork on D6
yeah maybe maybe actually United Trump
which was so tempting there it was also
my my first feeling that again Knight H5
when we just win the game and Prague
only needed this one little chance to to
to at least put up yeah Hans of course
correctly sacrifices The Exchange
because he has so such a domination yeah
he should just just not lose his
initiative